Dr Wallach LeBron James's son just had a
heart attack yesterday that fortunately
he is in stable condition what message
would you send out to him his family and
all parents who have kids that are
athletic
okay well when you're an athlete you
sweat
okay sweat out nutrients and does eating
well will not be enough to replace a
nutrients you're sweating out the more
you exercise the more nutritional and
deficient you become
okay unless you're supplementing to
replace them not only replace them but
build a reserve okay and
um the you see this all the time you
look at Fox News
um two or three times a day and there
there's these kids just like Ronnie
James who's 18 years old when he had his
heart attack yesterday 18 years old okay
a basketball player he's the oldest son
of LeBron James famous basketball player
and and it's very very common uh they're
sweating out all these nutrients and
this is the same heart attack that
babies used to get when they had
cinnamon death syndrome SIDS okay same
heart attack when you're three months
old the doctors are blaming the mothers
for laying on the babies and suffocating
them okay and um I figured out what it
was and basically it's just a simple
nutritional deficiency disease of a
nutrient and my attorney John Seymour
and I we sued the FDA
um eight times in federal court to get
these nutrients put into the baby Farms
like Infamous Similac that kind of thing
and suddenly now the sediment death
syndrome thing went away because it was
just a simple nutritional deficiency
disease and same thing here
when you're drinking the colas and
you're drinking all that kind of stuff
water carbonated water to hydrate juices
a lot of sugar plus the hydration and
you're not getting the nutrients you
need to give your heart what it needs to
function properly and maintain itself
and repair itself with all the activity
going on
you know I played Sports in junior high
high school and University I wrestled I
played football soccer weight lifted
track and field and I'm taking all these
vitamins and minerals and I'm doing fine
okay and it's one of those things where
I'm 84 years old now most people think
I'm in my 50s or 60s looking at me all
right but this is easily prevented and
easily reversed if they survive this
first attack but you want to get them on
the 90 essential nutrients okay one
healthy brain and hard pack for 100
pounds of body weight
one of the bottles of the MSM they'll
allow you to take three three times a
day of the MSM it's going to support and
promote mange repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue all that kind
of stuff they need the ultimate daily
classic tablets take three of those
twice a day those two bottles a month to
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries in the brain the heart
to the kidneys legs chest every place
you can think of
and this four shrink should actually be
our rebound our Rebound Sports rank has
75 minerals in it and 25 vitamins amino
acids Red Bull with the most prominent
most sold most purchased of all the
um sports drinks and energy drinks Red
Bull only has one mineral and a
magnesium
okay and um you're supposed to get the
rest from eating well you can't do it
because plants don't make minerals
plants do make vitamins amino acids
fatty acids but plants do not make
minerals nutritional minerals do not
occur in a uniform blanket around the
coast of the Arizona veins like gold and
silver
and so people who luck out and are
eating food they grew in a place where
there's lots of minerals and soil
they're getting their minerals but
they're eating plants that look just
like the ones that had a lot of minerals
in it they don't have many minerals in
them they can't tell the difference
between looking at them
and they only have three minerals in it
which made the plants happy you're in
trouble okay and so that's why we came
up with these these complete systems for
the rebound for our athletes as well as
for
um 600 different diseases we have
programs for 600 different diseases and
you you want to start
at least six months before the pregnancy
discharge okay and so we want the the
kids to be doing well we want the kids
who are going to be parents in the near
future or even distant future to be
supplementing properly in their sports
drinks as well as their their supplement
programs
and they're uh especially if they're
working in a factory they're sweating or
they're exercising uh for an hour a day
or three days a week at the gym or
whatever it might be uh exercise can
kill you because exercise is not it's a
negative if you're not supplementing to
replace all the nuisance you're you're
sweating out okay we're using wood and
coal as fuel and people were putting the
wood ashes in their food they're putting
wood ashes in their Garden same way as
coal ashes and the wooden coal ashes are
95 minerals and two or three percent
carbon
well three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 on Pearl
Street in New York City in the bluff
we're living in the construction of
Brooklyn Bridge now an assassin pulls
the switch
okay sadly now
there were no more sources of minerals
because electricity there's no side
benefit of minerals uh minerals being
produced like there are when you use
wooden coals fuel okay so suddenly now
we didn't have minerals anymore and
that's why you had to settlement with
all 90 ascensioners including all 60
essential minerals and of course we do
have a book it talks about the
transition okay it's called Hell's
Kitchen and the transition thank you
thank you Rebecca the transition between
wood and coal is fuel where we're
getting our minerals from the wood ashes
and coal Ashes to going to
electricity suddenly now there were no
more minerals in our diet anymore
okay and that's that's where the problem
came in so
so heart attacks are caused by nutrient
deficiencies caused by mineral
deficiencies that's correct
all right folks sounds like a simple fix
to me that genetics in any way shape or
form
so for those that have had a heart
attack Dr Wallach is there a chance of
being able to give the body what it
needs so that they can reduce the risk
of having another one of course
you want to start before you leave the
hospital okay don't wait until you're
home for a couple of months of your
reading and because you could have a
second heart attack okay as you're
pointing out so you want to get on these
nutrients and and don't skimp you're
going to save a lot of money by getting
rid of the bad foods bad foods cost a
lot of money so you'll save a lot of
money by getting rid of the bad food you
have enough money to buy the good foods
and again these things this this
information is unimpeachable we have and
we're coming up with a flip chart I know
you're involved heavily in getting a
slip chart out and this is you can talk
to your whole family with this flip
chart there's 65 pages in here talks
about all these things we just talked
about okay
okay and it's one of those things where
um the books and clip charts they'll
tell you what to do you have to do it
it's kind of like do you put dirt from
Texas in your car
because there's bound to be some oil in
it come on there's about to be some
wallets there's dirt from Texas I I only
have to pay 50 cents for 40 pounds okay
and I can use that in my car my gas tank
and my
um and my brake fluid and my
transmission fluid and all that kind of
stuff uh it'll be wonderful no you're
gonna die because your brakes won't work
your engine will burn up and you'll burn
up in the car with okay because
using using dirt from Texas is not going
to give you what you need to give your
car what it needs to doing the job you
wanted to do okay and you know that
people take much better care of their
car and then they take care of
themselves
and that analogy folks is just
that our food is grown in Senate
document what was it 264. 264 written in
1936 even said it and think about over
all this time over 80 years later
there's even less
so Dr Wallach thank you so much for your
time folks you can find the good foods
bad foods list at Daily withdoc.com and
make sure that you get back with the
person that shared this video with you
tell them thank you and ask them how you
also can get the products that Dr
Wallach is recommending that our
nutrient dense folks it's not
fractionated it's not a little bit of
this a little bit of that it's something
that is formulated to synergistically
work together within the body for
optimal results
bye for now
bye-bye